it's 11:00 p.m. you should be asleep but
you're watching a video on your phone
and tomorrow you'll wake up and go to
work where you'll stare at a computer
for eight hours when you get home you
might even watch a movie on TV so if
you're anything like the average
American adult you spend more than seven
hours a day staring at digital screens
so what's all this screen time actually
doing to your body and brain surprise
surprise humans did not evolve to stare
at bright electronic screens all day so
our eyes are suffering the consequences
an estimated 58% of people who work on
computers experience what's called
computer vision syndrome it's a series
of symptoms that include eye strain
blurred vision headaches and neck and
back pain and in the long term this
amount of screen time could be damaging
our vision permanently since 1971 cases
of nearsightedness in the US have nearly
doubled which some scientists partly
linked to increased screen time and in
Asia today nearly 90 percent of teens
and adults are nearsighted but it's not
just the brightness of our screens that
affect us it's also the color screens
emit a mix of red green and blue light
similar colors to sunlight and over
millennia it was blue wavelengths in
sunlight that helped us keep our
circadian rhythms in sync with our
environment but since our circadian
rhythms are more sensitive to blue light
than any others a problem occurs when we
use our screens at night typically when
the Sun sets we produce the hormone
melatonin this hormone regulates our
circadian rhythms helping us feel tired
and fall asleep many studies have found
that blue light from screens can disrupt
this process for example in one small
study participants who spent four hours
reading ebooks before bed five nights
produced 55 percent less melatonin than
participants who read print books
what's more the e-book readers reported
that they were more
alert before bed took longer to fall
asleep and reach restorative REM state
and were more tired the next morning but
perhaps the most concerning changes were
starting to see from all this screen
time is in kids brains an ongoing study
supported by the NIH has found that some
preteens who clocked over seven hours a
day on screens had differences in a part
of their brain called the cortex that is
the region responsible for processing
information from our five senses usually
the cortex gets thinner as we mature but
these kids had thinner Cortex's earlier
than other kids who spent less time on
screens scientists aren't sure what this
could mean for how the kids learn and
behave later in life but the same data
also showed that kids who spent more
than two hours a day on screens scored
lower in thinking and in language skill
tests to be clear the NIH data can't
confirm if more time spent staring at
screens causes these effects but they'll
have a better idea of any links as they
continue to follow and study these kids
over the next decade it's no doubt that
screens have changed the way we
communicate but only time will tell what
other changes are on the horizon for
humankind
you
[Music]